ils sont afghans irakiens ou pakistanais
ses joueurs composent l'équipe des
crickets star de saint-omer réfugié en
france ils ont commencé ce sport depuis
leur plus jeune âge
c'est le cas de samir ait said en
afghanistan quand je suis protégé
regardant la télé cricket a beaucoup des
joueurs
mon frère mon grand frère et léger avec
des mines nationales afghanistan et à
j'ai joué avec elle un petit peu un
petit pot après je comprends bien
truquée après j'aime cricket j'ai pris
là bas quand j'étais beach et j'espère
ans là bas et je suis venu ici en france
j'ai choisi rakic est bahia qui est
centenaire j'en a présenté là-bas au
score par un entraînement à la ben tout
les semaines on les semaines pour une
fois ça y est bien un sport une passion
pour ces joueurs un match caritatif
organisé par le lions ce club centenaire
joue ce jour là face à l'équipe de
cricket de thoiry
quand on est experte ray quand on est
étranger dans un pay le sport se joue un
rôle important pour réunir des gens des
communautés entre eux donc c'est déjà
les différentes communautés chacun a sa
propre culture est il écrit keith c'est
un moyen de faire mélange de communauté
je trouvais les lévriers un bonne équipe
et léa manque un peu d'entraînement
parce que j'ai tendu il n'a pas de
terrain dans ici en france
pour cela il a manqué pour entraînements
sinon il ya les bonnes équipes ne finit
avec l'étiquette star de saint-omer vont
devoir continuer à s'entraîner pour
renforcer le collectif
ils sont en attente d'une réponse de la
mairie pour obtenir un terrain et
s'entraîner dans de meilleures
conditions